>> Laura: IN 2015, HE BECAME
AN OUTSPOKEN VOICE FOR THE
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY.
A YEAR LATER HE WAS PRAISED FOR
BEING THE FIRST AMERICAN TO BE
LEGALLY RECOGNIZED FOR WHAT THEY
CALL NONBINARY.
JAMIE SHUPE WAS THE DARLING OF
THE LGBTQ WORLD.
INSTEAD OF RECOGNIZING A
DESPERATE CRY FOR HELP, DOCTORS,
JUDGES AND ACTIVISTS USED HIM TO
ADVANCE THE CAUSE, HE SAYS.
THEY TOOK ADVANTAGE OF HIS
VULNERABILITY AS AN ARMY VETERAN
SUFFERING FROM PTSD TO BREAK
BARRIERS.
JAMIE SHUPE WILL NEVER BE THE
SAME.
JOINING ME NOW TO TELL HIS STORY
AND IT'S SHOCKING, IS JAMIE
SHUPE HIMSELF.
JAMIE, THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
TAKES A LOT OF COURAGE TO BE
HERE.
YOU SAY THAT THE TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY HAS NOT ONLY TURNED
THEIR BACKS ON YOU BUT ARE NOW
ATTACKING YOU?
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> THAT'S CORRECT, LAURA.
THE MINUTE YOU DENOUNCE ANYTHING
TRANSGENDER IS UNWISE, YOU'RE
AUTOMATICALLY AN OUTCAST.
FOR EXAMPLE, I SUPPORT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BAN ON
TRANSGENDER MILITARY SERVICE.
I DO NOT AGREE WITH
TRANSITIONING CHILDREN OR
TRANSGENDER SURGERIES.
I'M AGAINST ALL OF THIS.
>> Laura: DID YOU TAKE THE
HORMONES AND START DOING ALL
THAT?
YOU DIDN'T OBVIOUSLY DO SURGERY
I GUESS BUT YOU DID START TAKING
ESTROGEN AND PROGESTERONE, WHAT
DID YOU DO?
>> YES, I TOOK ESTROGEN AND
PROGESTERONE AND NOW HAVE
IRREVERSIBLE BREAST GROWTH.
I HAVE A NUMBER OF HEALTH
PROBLEMS.
BONE DENSITY, KIDNEY PROBLEMS.
I ONE POINT MY MENTAL HEALTH WAS
SO DESTABILIZED THAT I HAD TO GO
STAYS IN THE PSYCHIATRIC WARD
BECAUSE OF IT.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK THIS
KIND OF PUSH IS BEING USED
BROADLY, MORE BROADLY?
I HEAR FROM A LOT OF PEOPLE, YOU
SEE A LOT OF EXAMPLES.
HERITAGE FOUNDATION DID A BIG
PANEL OF FEMINISTS WHO ARE
ACTUALLY REALLY UPSET BY THIS
BECAUSE THEY THINK PEOPLE ARE
BEING KIND OF PUSHED INTO THIS,
YOU KNOW, THIS KIND OF VIEW OF
LIFE AND TRANSGENDER IS HIM
BEFORE THEY REALLY KIND OF
NUMBER THEY ARE.
IS THAT WRONG?
>> NO, THAT'S COMPLETELY CORREC
CORRECT.
MY HAT IS OFF TO THE HERITAGE
FOUNDATION BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
THE ONLY PLACE THAT PEOPLE SUCH
AS MYSELF AND THESE RADICAL
FEMINISTS ARE GETTING A VOICE.
WE'VE BEEN COMPLETELY SILENCED
BY THE LEFT.
AS YOU SAID, I WAS PREVIOUSLY A
TRANSGENDER MEDIA DARLING
ANOTHER "NEW YORK TIMES" DOESN'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT ME ANYMORE OR
EVENING KNOWLEDGE THAT I EXIST
BECAUSE I KNOW LONGER SUPPORT
THIS STUFF.
THE CONSERVATIVES ARE TO BE
COMMENDED FOR WHAT THEY ARE
DOING TO HELP US, TO HELP
CHILDREN.
TO BE YOU TALKED TO OTHER PEOPLE
WHO WILL BEGAN TRANSITIONING AND
MAYBE EVEN DIDN'T TRANSITION?
THEY REACHED OUT TO YOU, IF THEY
HAVE REGRETS, DO THEY LOOK TO
FOR ADVICE?
OR JUST TO SHARE A STORY?
>> YES, LAURA.
REGRET IS VERY COMMON BUT AGAIN
THE MEDIA DOESN'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE SURGERIES THAT GO
WRONG AND THE HOST OF HEALTH
COMPLICATIONS.
IT'S REALLY WRONG TO EVEN CALL
THIS TRANSITION BECAUSE GENDER
IDENTITY IS LEGAL FICTION.
FIRST THEY CLAIMED THAT I WAS A
WOMAN AND THEN THEY CLAIMED THAT
I WAS A COMBINATION OF MALE AND
FEMALE AND EVERYBODY WENT ALONG
WITH THIS.
AS I SAID, IT'S NOTHING BUT
LEGAL FICTION.
>> Laura: SERGEANT, WE WISH
YOU THE BEST.
I KNOW IT'S INCREDIBLE -- IT
SOUNDS INCREDIBLY TRAUMATIC AND
DIFFICULT, AND I HOPE YOU'LL
STAY IN TOUCH WITH US AND WE'LL